[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Ela hat sich heute Cupcakes gewünscht.
Wir werden Rainbow Dash Cupcakes machen.
Und jetzt hat sie gesagt,
sie lernt noch ein bisschen und malt ein bisschen
und ich darf hier die Rainbow Dashs ausschneiden.
Denn das werden Cake Topper.
Und ich habe die einfach ausgedruckt.
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: Aha! Da bist du.
>> ELA: Ich habe bis 100 gerechnet!
>> SALLY: Hast du was?
>> ELA: Ich habe bis 100 gerechnet.
>> SALLY: Du hast bis 100 gerechnet?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Boah! Was gibt denn 50 plus 50?
>> ELA: Weiß ich noch nicht.
>> SALLY: 100.
Warte. Das habe ich angefangen.
Wir holen dir eine kleine Schere.
Und guck mal. Die schneiden wir jetzt aus,
lassen so einen kleinen weißen Rand
und dann laminieren wir sie ein
und schneiden sie noch mal aus.
Und zwar fragen jetzt vielleicht manche:
"Wieso laminierst du sie nicht ein
und scheidest sie dann aus?"
Dann hast du aber außen so einen Papierrand
und sie sind nicht komplett eingeschweißt.
Und deswegen erst ausschneiden,
laminieren und noch mal ausschneiden.
Dann sind sie hundert Prozent dicht.
Vor allem auch,
weil sie ja später in die Cupcakes reinkommen.
Und glaubt mir, vertraut mir.
Ich war lange genug Grundschullehrerin
und habe lange genug laminiert.
>> ELA: Das ist cool. Wisst ihr warum?
Weil es ist...
Ich habe sie hinten hingemacht,
weil sie so schnell ist.
>> SALLY: Und dann hat die da so Linien?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: So. Wie wäre es, wenn wir,
wenn du jetzt schon da bist, die Muffins schon mal backen?
Dann können die in den Backofen.
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Gut. Dann Schürze an, Hände waschen.
>> ELA: Mama. Mama. Mama.
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys und Elas Welt!
>> SALLY: Sollen wir noch mal zusammen?
>> ELA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Wir backen heute Muffins für mich.
Also ich habe mir die Figur Rainbow Dash ausgedacht.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt Rainbow Dash Muffins.
>> SALLY: Zeig mal Rainbow Dash.
Das ist Rainbow Dash. Ja.
Und Ela hat sich das ausgedacht.
Und warum ist Rainbow Dash so besonders?
>> ELA: Weil
sie talentiert schnell ist mit ihren Flügeln.
>> SALLY: Uh!
Ganz talentiert.
Hast du auch ein Talent?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und was ist das?
>> ELA: Kunststück.
>> SALLY: Kunststücke?
>> ELA: Auf Fahrrad.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Dafür, dass du es erst gelernt hast,
mit dem Fahrrad zu fahren,
super. Sehr gut.
Sehr
selbstbewusst.
Also wir haben die ja, wie gesagt, schon ausgeschnitten.
Da machen wir gleich weiter.
Aber jetzt werden wir erst mal den Muffinsteig machen.
Und, Ela, findest du es okay,
wenn wir gelbe Förmchen nehmen?
>> ELA: Nein!
>> SALLY: Weil guck mal, ich habe mir gedacht,
weil doch die Strähne vorne von Rainbow Dash
auch so gelb und rot und orange ist,
wenn man das so später reinmacht,
sieht doch bestimmt cool aus.
>> ELA: Aber, Mama, ich glaube...
>> SALLY: Oder weiße Förmchen?
>> ELA: Warte, Mama.
Ich weiß, welche Förmchen gut passen.
>> SALLY: Man darf Kindern nie
eine zu große Auswahl geben.
Eigentlich gar keine Auswahl.
Setzt sie einfach vor
die Entscheidung und sagt: "Hier,
gelbe Förmchen."
Und entweder können wir Grün nehmen,
Lila...
>> ELA: Pink auch?
>> SALLY: Pink? Aber Pink hat Rainbow Dash nicht drin.
Und Pink haben wir nur noch ganz wenige. Die reichen nicht.
Also ich kann dir Lila,
Weiß
>> ELA: Lila!
>> SALLY: oder Grün anbieten.
Ich habe
sofort Lila gesagt.
>> SALLY: "Ich habe Lila gesagt." Ja.
>> ELA: Gesagt!
>> SALLY: Also willst du Lila?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Guck mal. So sieht es mit Lila aus, so dunkel.
Und so sieht es mit Gelb aus, ein bisschen heller.
>> ELA: Okay.
Lila.
Jetzt sage ich, ich möchte Lila, Lila, Lila.
Lila, Lila.
>> SALLY: Kind will Lila.
Okay. Weißt du was?
Wir machen halb, halb.
Wir machen die Hälfte Lila
und die Hälfte Gelb, okay?
>> ELA: Hm?
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Bist du einverstanden?
>> SALLY: Gut.
Also das nennt sich ein Kompromiss.
Wir sind einen Kompromiss eingegangen.
Ja?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Denn jetzt machen wir etwas,
was mir gefällt und was dir gefällt.
Ja?
>> ELA: Ja.
Hm.
>> SALLY: Gut.
Also jetzt machen wir erst mal den Muffinsteig.
Da nehmen wir jetzt einen hellen Teig mit Streuseln.
Und wir zeigen erst mal die Zutaten, nicht?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Für die Muffins nehmen wir
150 Gramm Zucker und eine Prise Salz,
200 Gramm Mehl,
einen halben Teelöffel Backpulver
und einen viertel Teelöffel Natron,
100 Gramm Mandeln,
zwei Eier,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
150 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl,
100 Gramm Buttermilch
und 40 Gramm Streusel.
Okay.
Guck mal, ich kann schon mal die Mandeln mahlen.
Das mache ich hier kurz hier drin, okay?
>> ELA: Ja, das weiß ich,
das hatte ich mir schon gedacht.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Was mache ich dann jetzt?
>> SALLY: Warte.
So gut?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir das ein bisschen so stückig lassen?
Ja, nicht?
>> ELA: Nein, wir lassen es einfach so.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir lassen es so. Okay.
Jetzt darfst du die Mandeln hier reinschütten.
Hierher.
>> ELA: Da rein?
Wow!
>> SALLY: Genau.
Und da gibst du jetzt einfach alle trockenen Zutaten rein,
alles, was trocken ist,
Salz,
>> ELA: Trocken.
>> SALLY: Zucker, Mehl,
Backpulver und Natron.
>> ELA: Jetzt kommt der Zucker.
Der Zucker, der fällt so.
Und die nassen Zutaten brauchen wir erst,
wenn wir...
So.
Hier sind jetzt die trockenen Zutaten.
>> SALLY: Die darfst du verrühren.
>> ELA: Und, Mama,
wie wäre es, wenn du die verrührst
und ich mache die da rein?
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Immer erst mal ein Ei.
>> SALLY: Ein Ei nach dem anderen, sage ich immer.
Aber hier darfst du jetzt gleich beide Eier reintun,
beide Eier reingeben.
Ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt.
Das reicht.
Das sind jetzt Vanillemuffins.
>> ELA: Joghurt.
>> SALLY: Und guck mal beim Öl,
bitte tu mir jetzt einen Gefallen
und, wenn du es jetzt reinschüttest,
auf einmal reinschütten, ja?
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Dann verkleckerst du nicht.
Buttermilch rein.
Ja.
Und jetzt erst mal alle nassen Zutaten verrühren.
>> ELA: Und dann die...
>> SALLY: Die Streusel machen wir ganz zum Schluss.
Ich glaube, wir erhöhen noch die Buttermilchmenge, nicht?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Auch auf 150 Gramm.
>> ELA: Mama, komm,
wir machen die trockenen Zutaten jetzt schon mal rein.
>> SALLY: Nee, warte. Wir machen noch Buttermilch rein,
ein bisschen.
Hier noch ein bisschen Buttermilch.
>> ELA: Eins, zwei, drei, go!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Jetzt dürfen meine trockenen Zutaten
zu deinen flüssigen Zutaten
und dürfen vermischt werden.
Ja.
>> ELA: Von mir?
>> SALLY: Ja,
von dir ganz alleine.
>> ELA: Ups!
Ich habe auch ein bisschen verkleckert.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Also jetzt haben wir ja Vanillemuffins, nicht?
>> ELA: Da will ich...
>> SALLY: Riecht gut.
Und wie schmeckt es?
Sehr gut!
Und was kommt jetzt noch?
>> ELA: Und zum Schluss...
>> SALLY: Zum Schluss die bunten Konfettistreusel!
Die gibt es übrigens in jedem Supermarkt.
[Musik]
Guck mal. Und jetzt nehmen wir den großen Eisportionierer.
Da muss man jetzt aber ganz arg aufpassen
und jetzt nicht so arg kleckern.
Und jetzt kommt hier ein Eisportionierer voll
>> ELA: Darf ich auch?
>> SALLY: – ja –
immer in so ein Muffinförmchen.
Warte. Komm mal, nimm mal so.
Nimm mal so.
Guck mal, ich streife es dir mal ab.
Und
jetzt hier rein,
rein mit, alles.
>> ELA: Ich helfe dir auch.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich sehe es, wie du mir hilfst.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm?
Kann ich dieses rosa Förmchen wegnaschen?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> ELA: Warum?
>> SALLY: Da ist jetzt zu viel rohes Ei drin
und Mehl, was nicht gebacken ist.
Okay.
Dann kriegt man da ganz arg Bauchschmerzen.
[Pfiff von Ela]
>> ELA: Ich mache hier mal hier sauber so.
>> SALLY: Oje!
>> ELA: Auch das Blech.
>> SALLY: Hauptsache, sie kann pfeifen.
Hauptsache, das Kind kann pfeifen.
>> ELA: Soll ich mal die Schüssel sauber machen?
>> SALLY: Ja, aber im Waschbecken
und nicht mit deinem Mund.
Also komm.
Los, zum Backofen.
Nimmst du die zwei mit?
>> ELA: Ja.
Kann ich...
Ich mache die da rein, okay, Mama?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Mama?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Warte. Aber nicht mit der Hand reingehen, ja?
>> ELA: Warum?
>> SALLY: Der ist ganz, ganz, ganz heiß, der Ofen!
Der ist schon vorgeheizt.
Jetzt gebe ich die am besten hier so vorne dran.
Ta-taa!
[Musik]
Und jetzt schneide ich sie aber eher rundlich zu hier,
damit sich die Kinder nicht daran schneiden.
Also keine scharfen Ecken.
Die Muffins sind fertig.
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt kommt die Creme an die Reihe.
Die Muffins haben wir natürlich komplett abkühlen lassen.
Und jetzt gibt es eine Frischkäse-Quark-Sahne-Creme.
Wer keinen Frischkäse mag,
ersetzt ihn einfach durch Quark.
Wer keinen Quark mag,
nimmt einfach Frischkäse stattdessen.
Und es ist auch eine richtig einfache Creme
und lecker zugleich.
Die wird dann eingefärbt und das ist dann
– wie heißt das Pony? –
>> ELA: Rainbow Dash!
>> SALLY: Rainbow Dashs Schweif.
Also was nehmen wir dafür?
Wir brauchen
200 Gramm Frischkäse,
200 Gramm Quark,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
80 Gramm Puderzucker,
400 Gramm Sahne,
San-apart zum Steifschlagen
und die Lebensmittelfarben
Gelb,
Blau
und
Rot.
>> ELA: Wir haben ja schon die Muffins gemacht.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt die Creme.
Oder, Mama?
>> SALLY: Ja!
So machen wir das.
Okay.
Guck mal. Jetzt kommt einfach
der Frischkäse in die Rührschüssel.
>> ELA: Da der Frischkäse.
Bumm!
>> SALLY: Und dann Quark.
>> ELA: Quark.
>> SALLY: Jetzt nehmen wir hier
>> ELA: Piek.
>> SALLY: Vanilleextrakt,
dein Spezialgebiet.
Das reicht.
Das reicht!
>> ELA: Ich habe mehr genommen.
Und jetzt?
>> SALLY: Sie erhöht meinen Vanilleextraktverbrauch im Jahr.
Puderzucker.
Und jetzt wird ganz kurz erst mal verrührt.
>> ELA: Ja.
Darf ich?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Warte. Ich schalte ein bisschen höher.
[Musik]
Jetzt darfst du langsam die Sahne dazu gießen.
>> ELA: Einmal die Sahne.
>> SALLY: Ganz langsam.
Langsam!
>> ELA: Ganz langsam.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt nimmst du immer
– genau, San-apart habe ich hier drin.
Schau mal. Ich zeige dir mal was.
Jetzt immer so einen Löffel nehmen,
ein bisschen abschütteln
und genau einen Teelöffel immer rein, ja?
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt zählen wir mit.
Eins.
Jetzt pro 100 Gramm Masse einen Teelöffel,
also acht.
Acht Stück brauchen wir.
>> SALLY & ELA: Zwei.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Drei.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Vier.
>> ELA: Ups!
Fünf.
>> SALLY: Wie viele waren es?
>> ELA: Fünf.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Sechs.
>> ELA: Sieben.
Die letzte Zahl ist?
>> SALLY: Acht.
>> ELA: Acht.
>> SALLY: Super!
Jetzt den Deckel wieder drauf.
Teelöffel raus.
>> ELA: Der kommt jetzt da raus.
>> SALLY: Und gleich machen wir sauber, okay?
Jetzt könnt ihr die Creme steifschlagen.
>> ELA: Da ist noch ein bisschen was drin.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Super!
>> ELA: Jetzt?
>> SALLY: Und
>> ELA: Kann ich probieren?
>> SALLY: fertig.
Hier kannst du probieren.
Hauptsache, immer so ein ganzer Finger voll.
Und?
Schmeckt die Creme?
>> ELA: Schmeckt nach Honig.
>> SALLY: Nach Honig?
Uh!
Also gut?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
Jetzt teilen wir die Creme kurz auf
auf kleine Schälchen, um sie dann einzufärben.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Will das jemand abschlecken?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und das?
>> ELA: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich erst mal ganz wenig nur rein,
damit wir am Anfang das hier mit der Creme
mit der Farbe verrühren können.
Ja, nur so ein bisschen.
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann rühren wir den Rest rein.
Ja, den können wir dann unterheben.
Also wir machen Blau, Gelb.
>> ELA: Das da?
>> SALLY: Blau, Gelb, Rot. Und die willst auch noch Lila?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Weil Lila ist die schönste Farbe einfach.
Mit Pink.
Kann ich hier mal Gelb irgendwo reinmachen?
>> SALLY: Ja, du kannst Gelb hier reinmachen.
>> ELA: So. Jetzt reicht es.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Weißt du was?
Aus Blau und Gelb können wir noch Grün machen.
Wie wäre es?
>> ELA: Ja.
Bei mir ist es schon mal fertig.
Mama, bei mir ist es schon mal...
>> SALLY: Fertig!
>> ELA: Und bei mir ist schon mal...
>> SALLY: Guck mal, was für ein cooles Grün!
>> ELA: Darf ich machen, Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Grün kommt hier mal.
[Musik]
Mama, das Grün ist auch fertig!
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Violett!
>> SALLY: Welches Kind sagt "Violett"?!
>> SAMIRA: Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Lila Violett heißt.
>> ELA: Ja.
Mit Nachnamen heißt das einfach Violett.
>> SALLY: Der Nachname.
Ha ja, der Nachname von Lila ist einfach Violett.
>> ELA: Weil Violett ist ja wie Lila.
>> SAMIRA: Weil die meisten sagen ja Lila.
>> ELA: Und die meisten sagen Violett.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir müssen einfach Ela fragen.
Die Ela, die weiß das.
Ja, das sieht gut aus.
Und jetzt gebe ich hier jeweils
die Creme dazu.
Und jetzt schön unterheben, gell?
>> ELA: Hm.
Bei Violett auch?
>> SALLY: Bei Violett auch.
Und da färbt ihr auch am besten
immer mit Lebensmittelfarbpasten.
Die verändern die Konsistenz nämlich nicht
und da braucht man auch nicht so viel.
>> ELA: Mama, Mama, Mama!
>> SALLY: So, Ela, schau mal.
>> ELA: Mama, kannst du mir ein bisschen Violett
geben noch mal?
>> SALLY: Ja. Warte.
Ich helfe dir ganz kurz beim Unterheben.
Die färben auch ein bisschen nach.
Die werden noch ein bisschen dunkler dann.
Zeig mal her.
Du musst nicht immer alles probieren.
Hallo?!
>> ELA: Aber ich bin die Testerin.
>> SALLY: Die Testerin?
Aber dann haben wir gleich keine Creme mehr für
die Cupcakes.
[Musik]
Jetzt probieren wir mal was aus.
Ich habe ja schon öfter Rainbow Muffins gemacht
oder auch mal mit verschiedenfarbigen Cremes
als Topping auf Cupcakes drauf gespritzt.
Jetzt machen wir es mal so,
ich nehme eine Frischhaltefolie hier.
Und ich möchte jetzt einfach nicht,
dass sich die Farben im Spritzbeutel vermischen,
sondern wirklich erst, kurz bevor sie praktisch
auf die Muffins drauf gespritzt werden.
Jetzt kommt praktisch jede Farbe für sich
in so einen Spritzbeutel.
>> ELA: Mama, machst du jetzt daraus einen Spritzbeutel?
>> SALLY: – in eine Frischhaltefolie.
Warte. Ich hole eine Karte.
Und jetzt wird daraus eine Rolle gemacht.
Siehst du?
>> ELA: Damit man es als Spritzbeutel verwenden kann?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und das mache ich jetzt ganz kurz mit allen so.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Aus Wurmi wird Sturmi!
>> SALLY: Ach, aus Wurmi wird Sturmi.
Okay.
>> ELA: Darf ich das mit der Karte machen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Okay.
Dann wickel die mal ein,
die kleine grüne Wurst.
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
Fertig.
>> SALLY: Guck, jetzt so.
Ja?
>> ELA: Okay, Mama.
Darf ich?
Mama, ich muss mal.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Super machst du das!
>> ELA: Mama, du rollst ein
und ich mache das wieder mit der Karte, okay?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Aber diesmal allein, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Und noch mal ein bisschen einrollen.
>> SALLY: Super!
Klasse!
Mensch, kannst du das schon toll!
>> SAMIRA: Blaukraut.
>> ELA: Nein!
Kraut! Einfach nur Kraut!
Darf ich dann wieder mit dem,
mit der Scheibe machen?
>> SALLY: Hm.
[Musik]
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir das als Wurst.
Gut!
>> ELA: Alle haben wir als Wurst.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt nehmen wir einen großen Spritzbeutel,
eine große Sterntülle.
Das ist so eine fein gezackte.
So. Hier vorne wegschneiden,
Spritztülle rein.
Oh, das war zu klein.
Aber ich wollte es nicht aus Versehen
zu groß machen, weißt du?
>> SAMIRA: Dann flutscht es unten raus.
>> SALLY: Sonst flutscht es raus.
Und jetzt hier unten einschlagen.
So.
Jetzt legen wir diese ganzen Farben rein.
Aber das machen wir jetzt alles gemeinsam.
Und hier schneide ich jetzt vorne
einfach diese freie Spitze weg.
Guck mal.
Und dann legen wir sie so
>> SALLY & ELA: hier rein.
>> SALLY: So.
Jetzt haben wir unseren Masterspritzbeutel
mit den vielen Farben.
>> ELA: Mama, darf ich die Farben machen?
>> SALLY: Das stellen wir jetzt aber
kurz mal in den Kühlschrank
Die Creme ist jetzt echt weich geworden.
Denn wir haben viel lange rumgerührt.
Und ich stelle sie kurz kühl,
dass sie kalt wird.
Also jetzt den Spritzbeutel oben immer gut festhalten,
zuhalten,
senkrecht halten und dann...
>> ELA: Wow!
>> SALLY: Nicht?
>> ELA: Wenn du alle fertig hast,
dann esse ich meinen Marshmallow auf,
meinen kleinen auf.
Okay?
Meinen Cupcake.
>> SALLY: Jetzt sieht das doch aus wie,
als wäre das von Rainbow Dash der Schweif, oder?
[Musik]
Zack.
So?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Rainbow Dash Cupcakes, he?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Tschakka!
Ta-taa!
Dein Rainbow Dash!
>> ELA: Ich kann es sogar von...
>> SAMIRA: Kann ich mir auch einen nehmen?
>> SALLY: Gleich.
Na, wie schmeckt es?
>> ELA: Super!
>> SALLY: Soll ich das mal kurz wegnehmen?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Deine Zunge ist gleich ganz bunt!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Warte mal.
>> ELA: Wie bei My Little Pony.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt mit Teig,
mit Kuchen, nicht?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Njam!
>> ELA: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und?
Test bestanden?
Super!
Also, wenn ihr auch
die Rainbow Dash Cupcakes machen wollt,
dann schaut gerne in meiner kostenlosen App vorbei
oder auf sallys-blog.de.
Da stehen noch mal alle Zutaten.
Ich dekoriere die jetzt noch kurz fertig,
stelle sie kühl.
Was wir eigentlich noch machen wollten, war,
dass wir hier oben noch
so kleine Mini-Marshmallows drauf setzen.
Aber die hat jemand aufgegessen.
>> ELA: Ich.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte keinen Namen verraten.
Aber ja, sie war es.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ah, Ela, was ich noch wissen wollte:
Du hast doch mal erzählt,
da gibt es doch diese Elemente der Harmonie.
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber was bedeutet das denn?
>> ELA: Dass die halt sehr...
Dass die Kraft halt besser wird.
>> SALLY: Ah!
Und was sind denn Elemente der Harmonie?
>> ELA: Was?
>> SALLY: Was gibt es da für Elemente?
>> ELA: Da ist so ein Edelstein.
Da ist in der Mitte immer so ein Edelstein.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Das ist aus Gold
>> ELA: halt.
Und dann...
Es gibt eine Halskette.
Die Krone, die gehört dann...
Aber
nur ein...
>> SALLY: Gibt es da nicht irgendwie so...
Hast du nicht mal gesagt, so Freundlichkeit und Ehrlichkeit
oder irgendwie so was?
Ja?
Egal.
Das können wir ja nächstes Mal noch mal ansprechen.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
[Musik]